after two weeks at sea climate activists
Greta toon burg arrives in New York the
sixteen year old doesn't fly so she
sailed across the Atlantic to attend the
United Nations climate summit
[Music]
[Applause]
despite the sea legs making dry land a
challenge she says it's been worth it
the ground is still shaking for me the
climate and ecological crisis is a
global crisis and the biggest crisis
humanity has ever faced and if we don't
manage to work together to cooperate and
to to work together despite our
differences then we will fail so we need
to to stand together and support each
other and and to take action because
otherwise it might be too late so let's
not wait any longer let's do it now it
hasn't been a straightforward journey
since the departure from Plymouth
there's been criticism too after it
emerged that crew members from the
melissia yacht would have to fly to New
York to sail it home again when we spoke
in Stockholm earlier this year she says
the constant scrutiny is just part of
what she believes is a fight for
survival does it ever feel like too much
of a burden to be the face of a global
movement I mean of course and I I think
I speak on behalf of all the children
and young people who are school striking
and organizing that we are I mean we are
just children we shouldn't have to do
this
the adults should take that
responsibility the grete toon Berg the
UN climate summit in September a chance
for nations around the world to rise to
that challenge as the window for making
an impact continues to narrow Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News